dominic rubb has been confirmed as the
new justice secretary lord chancellor
and the deputy prime minister now of
course he was previously the foreign
secretary
and the first secretary of state now
that will no doubt be seen as a demotion
by dominic rubb he was of course in that
very long meeting with boris johnson
inside the house of commons we then saw
him walk up downing street up the street
into number 10 a number of people
followed in behind advisors and the like
that appointment has been confirmed in
the last couple of moments now it's
unlikely to have been what dominic robb
wanted that meeting was understood to
have been quite fractious between the
pair
you know the prime minister clearly had
made his case for that change of role
which has now as i say been accepted and
confirmed by the team uh working with
dominic rubb but again it's a another
significant shift in a day where we've
seen some very senior people move out of
jobs where perhaps they hadn't wanted to
and the reaction to some of those moves
has been pretty mixed